[Musique]
à mes parents à mes amis moi je dis
bonne
année à mes cousins qui habite en Italie
moi je dis
B à tous les gens que je connais
moi je dis bonnene
année et à tous les gens tous les gens
j'aime
bien moi je dis bonnene
année à tous les gens à tous les gens
que je n'aime pas je n veux pas moi je
dis bonne
année et à tous les gens et à tous les
gens qui ne m'aime pas qui m'aime pas
moi je dis bonnene
année à tous les gens à tous les gens
que je ne connais pas que je ne connais
pas moi je dis bonne
année et à tous ceux à tous ceux qui
m'écoutent ce soir qui m'écoutent ce
soir moi je dis bonne
année à tous les petits noirs et tous
les petits chinois t lestit chinois moi
je dis
bon à tous les fonctionnaires
fonctionnaires et à tous les soldats les
soldats je bonne
année à tous les techniciens techici de
la télévision la télévision moi je dis
bonne
année et à Monsieur
gu et à tous les
téléspectateurs moi je dis
bonne
[Musique]